Joe Goldberg is back
and he hasn't changed
one bit.
You know the drill by now.
We'll be explaining
all you need to know
about the ending
of You season 3.
So, go make sure
you're all caught up
before
you continue watching.
The very final scene
of season 3
teases Joe's next steps,
but before we dig into that
we need to rewind
and take a look
at how he got here.
Starting with his new
and unfamiliar environment,
suburbia.
Which, as we well know,
is Joe's idea of hell.
We're in this fake,
plastic suburban hell.
We moved here for the baby.
Two extra things come
with his personal nightmare
in the aspirational
neighbourhood
of Madre Linda.
His wife,
Love Quinn Goldberg
and new born son, Henry,
also known as Forty
after Love's deceased twin,
much to Joe's annoyance.
Welcome home, Forty.
Maybe we can use
his real name.
New parenthood
may be exhausting
for Madre Linda's
new murderous couple,
but Joe still finds the time
to develop a new obsession
with their attractive
and flirtatious neighbour,
Natalie.
You're nervous.
Got a chequered past
you're trying hide?
While some habits die hard,
suburban Joe, it seems,
is not as prone to murder
as Joe in New York
and Joe in LA,
AKA the Joe's
of previous seasons.
In fact,
he doesn't kill anyone
until the last episode
but one.
More on that later.
The same, however,
can't be said for his wife.
As a result,
suburban Joe
spends most of this season
covering up his wife's
murders and misdeeds.
Love starts
with murdering Natalie
shortly after finding a box
full
of Natalie-related trinkets
collected by Joe.
She later attacks
mild-mannered
local geology professor,
Gil,
when he admits
his unvaccinated children
gave Henry/ Forty
the measles.
When he kills himself
in the now infamous cage
after she and Joe
dig up dirt on his son,
they pin
Natalie's murder on him,
successfully throwing
Madre Linda's
nosy neighbours
off their scent,
as well as, crucially,
the police.
All that is undone
when, during a swinging
party gone array,
Love let's
Natalie's murder slip
within earshot
of Madre Linda power couple,
Sherry and Cary.
-I killed Natalie for you!
-Shut up!
Go.
In the box they go
where they're discovered
by Natalie's stepson, Theo,
a lovesick teenager
fixated on Love
who's been more than happy
to encourage
that attraction.
Despite seeming
to care about him,
she attacks him
to protect her secret,
leaving him
for Joe to deal with.
So, it is safe to say
Love Quinn Goldberg
is more than a match for Joe
and with a murderous wife,
and obsession of Joe's
is faced
with a double threat,
being stalked by him
or killed by Love.
I think we need to go
to couple's therapy.
Enter Marienne,
Joe's boss
at the local library.
Their relationship
is initially frosty,
but thaws over of the season
as the two get closer.
We learn she's
a divorced single mother
and a former addict.
Part of the reason
Joe fixates on her so much
is because he believes
they have shared
similar struggles in life,
and with that,
he has a new target.
Aside from
the homicidal wife,
there is another man
standing in the way
of what Joe wants.
Local reporter, Ryan,
is Marienne's ex-husband,
gaming the system
to prevent her from getting
full custody
of her daughter.
Marienne makes it clear
any relationship
between the two of them
cannot happen
because he would use
her being with a married man
as a reason
to withhold her daughter.
And this is where
Joe decides
it's time to kill.
Not for Love,
not for his son,
but for Marienne.
It's for her.
With Ryan out of the way,
he decides it's time
to ask Love for a divorce
so he can run away
with Marienne and Juliette.
But Love isn't going to
let him leave that easily.
And it turns out,
she too has form
in the whole killing
romantic partners area.
Remember
her deceased husband
in season 2?
The official story
was he died of cancer,
but Love confesses
that the truth
is much more sinister.
I did kill him.
But I didn't mean to.
It was my first time
using it
and...
the dosage was too high
when ingested.
What dosage was too high?
Aconite.
-You wanted to paralyse him.
-You don't have to worry.
This time I'm letting it
absorb through the skin.
Oh, no. No, no, no, no, no.
Paralysing Joe
with aconite farmed
from a wolfsbane plant
she's been tending
whole season,
Love plots
to kill her rival, Marienne.
When he's
obsessed with someone,
he'll do anything
for them...
I should know.
He was obsessed with me.
Until he met you.
Mum?
...but she has
a change of heart
after seeing Juliette
and it's here, it seems,
Joe's time is up.
I'm not the problem.
My husband is the problem.
Unfortunately for Love,
Joe has been
one step ahead of her
the whole time.
He injects her with his own
lethal dosage of aconite,
admitting he knew she would
attempt something like this,
taking
some adrenaline tablets
to fend off
the effects of the poison.
Love dies
still insisting the two
are a match made in heaven.
We're perfect
for each other.
And, well,
she's probably not wrong.
Thanks to his staging
of the scene,
everyone believes
Joe is dead at Love's hands.
He cuts off his own toes,
leaving one baked in a pie
at the charred remains
of his family home.
All of the attacks
and murders
around Madre Linda,
including
that of reporter Ryan,
are pinned on her,
leaving Joe free and clear.
Sherry and Cary
survive the cage
by finding
the spare key inside
and make a killing
out of their experience.
Theo too survives
when Joe decides
to take him to a hospital,
instead of killing him
and clearing up Love's mess.
And little Henry
is given a new home
with Joe's
library colleague, Dante.
So, where has Joe gone next?
He can't return
to New York or LA,
two places
filled with his skeletons
and where people
would likely recognise him.
So, a new country
and city it is.
As that skyline makes clear,
Joe ends season 3 in Paris.
Why Paris?
Well, if you remember
earlier in the season,
Marienne tells Joe
she grew up there
and dreams
of taking Juliette there
away from Ryan
and away from Madre Linda.
I was born in Paris.
Once again,
Joe Goldberg follows a woman
to a brand new city
with a brand new name
and identity.
Will he find Marienne?
Well, that's a question
for another time.
What did you make
of the newest season of You?
Let us know in the comments
and for more breakdowns
of your favourite
Netflix shows,
make sure you subscribe
to the channel.